[Música]
buenas tardes
bueno hoy día quiero hablarle un poco de
lo que para mí es el secreto de la
felicidad me considero una persona
sumamente afortunada
porque estoy feliz y soy feliz y creo
que es importante
poder incluso transmitir esto la cosa es
que a veces muchas veces la gente habla
de felicidad sin saber bien que es hoy
día vamos a ver que para mí la felicidad
es una cosa muy sencilla y se puede
incluso resumir hablando de cuatro
puntos de verdad que hoy día va a ser
muy sencillo no vamos a hablar de
autoayuda no vamos a hablar de
pensamiento positivo vamos a hablar de
lo que para mí es el secreto de la
felicidad de los cuatro puntos de que
vamos a hablar hoy día son muy sencillos
vamos a hablar de la diferencia entre
hacer bien las cosas y hacer cosas
buenas vamos a hablar de alcanzar los
sueños vamos a hablar de la educación y
finalmente vamos a hablar de cambiar el
mundo
y es algo muy importante yo creo empezar
con la diferencia entre hacer bien las
cosas y hacer cosas buenas para cosas
que no sé para ustedes pero para mí ha
sido desde niño siempre el mismo refrán
y la cosa es que toda la sociedad la
familia los compañeros te dicen que
tienes que hacer bien las cosas y te
dicen todos no te dicen tienen que ser
bien las cosas en la escuela para ser un
buen alumno tiene que ser bien las cosas
la familia para ser un buen chico tiene
que ser bien las cosas en el trabajo y
al final yo estaba en mi doctorado y me
esforzaba me esforzaba mucho día y noche
trabajaba todos todo el día todos los
días para hacer las cosas bien
y nunca se acababa era una espiral y a
mí me ha costado mucho de verdad he
llegado llegado casi hasta el punto de
abandonar sobre todo el último año era
una cosa increíble había que servir las
cosas ya que ser bien las cosas hay que
servir las cosas
hasta hasta la cosa de hacer bien era
prácticamente el objetivo y 11 a veces
no se da cuenta pero es así para mí para
mí fue muy muy útil conocer a un docente
un docente que conocido a través de una
charla virtual como el tedh aunque no
conocía todavía alterna en ese momento
esto se sentirá randy pausch del
carnegie mellon college de norteamérica
y él me ha explicado que hay una muy
importante diferencia entre hacer bien
las cosas y hacer cosas buenas porque
solo hacer bien las cosas si no te paras
un minuto para entender qué cosa estás
haciendo bueno quizás quizás no valga la
pena porque hacer bien las cosas que
significa puedes estafar a un amigo muy
bien
puedes cometer el delito perfecto y has
hecho muy bien la cosa puedes robar algo
maravillosamente si son las cosas bien
y entonces me di cuenta que esta cosa de
hacer bien las cosas no es lo más
importante tenemos que decidir qué hacer
y las cosas que tenemos que hacer tienen
que ser cosas buenas tiene que valer la
pena porque ahí está todo el chiste en
el momento en que yo puedo cambiar la
perspectiva y ver que no es el esfuerzo
el objetivo el objetivo no es hacer bien
las cosas
esforzarte sobradas porque si el
esfuerzo es el objetivo nunca termina
nunca podrá terminar porque es cada vez
hay un esfuerzo mientras que la cosa
importante es hacer las cosas buenas y
bueno cuando empiezo a hacer las cosas
buenas quizás no soy un genio quizás la
primera vez que hago que hago algo me
equivoco habrás tropezones habrá
problemas y sin embargo vale la pena y
si estoy haciendo cosas buenas entonces
también vale la pena el esfuerzo vale la
pena no dormir va la pena meterle más
vale la pena trabajar el fin de semana
porque el objetivo es un medio
no es porque el esfuerzo es un medio no
es el objetivo y entonces de esta manera
tiene mucho más sentido ya no es el
esfuerzo por el esfuerzo sino puedo
simplemente concentrarme en las cosas
buenas y de ahí podemos dar el siguiente
paso el siguiente paso es que si voy a
hacer las cosas buenas y el esfuerzo no
es el objetivo entonces entonces puedo
alcanzar mis sueños
y bueno eso de alcanzar los sueños a
veces parece un poco un turístico
incluso muchos colegas me dicen que soy
soñador pero es algo muy importante y
muy sencillo cuál es el problema de
alcanzar los sueños el problema alcanzar
los sueños es que este milenio y sobre
todo su milenio la posmodernidad nos ha
dicho que está mal nos ha dicho que está
mal alcanzar los sueños porque porque
son ilusiones porque no lo vas a
alcanzar porque te esfuerzas por nada
incluso se puede entender no esto este
milenio viene después de un siglo con
muchos problemas con guerras con temas
donde era muy difícil alcanzar los
sueños
pero lo que pasa es que la sociedad les
dice que no vale la pena alcanzar los
sueños y más bien la sociedad del
posmodernismo le dice sabes que en vez
de alcanzar los sueños compran cosas
puedes comprar cosas porque los sueños
no lo vas a casar pero puedes comprar un
celular nuevo puedes comprarte ropa
puedes acumular y ahí estamos con el
problema porque este milenio nos ha
dicho que no podemos alcanzar los sueños
y podemos sustituirlo con cosas el
problema es que las cosas se rompen la
ropa pasa de moda y al final del día nos
quedamos con muy poca gente alrededor
y bueno ese es un problema es un
problema porque los sueños
vale la pena alcanzarlo y porque la
felicidad no está en las cosas cuando me
han preguntado si podía dar esta charla
generalidad y yo he dicho que quien
debería dar esta charla
es mi perrito
mi perrita ha entendido perfectamente lo
que es la felicidad mi perrita sabe lo
que es ser feliz mi perdida entendido
que es muy sencillo la ley de la lola
ella es un hombre nos dice que se
necesitan tres cosas para estar feliz
que necesitamos no la sabe que para
estar feliz necesito un techo bajo el
cual dormir un plato lleno de croquetas
y alguien que me rasqué la panza
y con esto yo puedo estar feliz
y no estoy diciendo que no me gustan las
cosas no estoy diciendo que no me gustan
los regalos no estoy diciendo que no me
gusta comprar cosas obviamente no seamos
hipócritas a todo le gusta si me regalan
cosas fantástico las uso lo que estoy
diciendo es que las cosas no son el
sustituto de la felicidad y una vez que
han entendido cómo lo ha entendido la
lola que estas cosas pueden ser buenas
pero no me dan la felicidad entonces
pueden trabajar con los sueños y lo que
a mí me hizo pensar y entender de verdad
lo que era el trabajo con los sueños fue
una figura muy importante en mi vida una
figura que para mí ha sido
incluso acompañándome un buen buen
trecho de mi vida
las cosas que yo antes de entender este
tema de alcanzar los sueños hacia lo que
hacen todos los estudiantes y los
jóvenes me quejaba me quejaba de
cualquier cosa me quejaba de los
horarios me quejaba de la universidad me
quejaba de los docentes me quejaba de
los exámenes porque nos gusta mucho
quejarnos no nos da gusto incluso nos
juntamos entre amigos y nos quedamos
aquí que sé que jamás es que mi profe no
pero el mío es como como si tuviéramos a
quien se puede quejar más es una cosa
que hacemos todos y obviamente lo hacía
también yo
lo hacía así de tanto
que casi no me daba cuenta
la persona que pudo hacerme dar cuenta
fue mi abuela la que pueden ver aquí mi
abuela hubiera podido hubiera querido
estudiar siempre me ha contado mi abuela
que cuando era niña soñaba con con ser
maestra
después un cambio en la vida subió el
problema a algunas situaciones una de
esas situaciones fue la segunda guerra
mundial por ejemplo y entonces mi abuela
no pudo estudiar
y no pudo aprender para ser maestra sin
embargo mi abuela pudo aprender a
escuchar y escuchaba muy muy bien
escuchaba tan bien incluso su nieto que
cada fin de semana volvía de la
universidad y se quejaba
medias horas una hora quejándose y bueno
mi abuela me escuchaba y me dejaba
desahogarme y un día cuando ajuste
estaba ahí ella estaba limpiando sus
verduras para la sopa del mediodía ello
con mi queja de que los horarios de que
los exámenes de que los profes etcétera
etcétera me dejó hablar a hablar
hasta cuando ya no tenía quejas y sin ni
siquiera mirarme seguir simplemente
limpiando sus verduras me comentó que me
dijo bueno de verdad que te creo debe
ser muy muy difícil desenvolverse en la
universidad mira ni siquiera me lo puedo
imaginar debe ser muy muy complicado ser
un estudiante universitario
fíjate que tu abuelo cuando tenía tu
edad estaba en un campo de concentración
alemán
y bueno esta cosa me puso un poquito en
perspectiva porque finalmente
bueno yo quizás te echa problemas con
los horarios de las clases y un profesor
que no me caía bien pero hoy me di
cuenta que finalmente a mí nadie me
había obligado nadie me había obligado a
escribir en la universidad nadie me
había obligado a estudiar japonés nadie
me ve obligado en tomar estos horarios y
trabajar más bien yo estaba y no me
estaba dando cuenta yo estaba siguiendo
mis sueños estaba justo trabajando para
mis sueños
y bueno era difícil y bueno significaba
trabajar en las noches sí pero
finalmente yo no me había dado cuenta
hasta ese momento que decenas y
centenares de personas habían luchado
habían sufrido y habían muerto para que
yo
puede escoger para que yo pueda decidir
para que yo pueda hacer lo que quería
hacer muchas generaciones no habían
tenido esa suerte yo podía escoger lo
que hacer podía escoger qué camino tomar
podía trabajar para mis sueños y eso era
gracias a personas como a ellas fue muy
importante para mí entenderlo y me puso
de nuevo un poco en la perspectiva
porque al final había entendido que si
podía trabajar para mis sueños y que si
valía la pena aunque sea por respeto
hacia las personas que habían luchado
para darme esta oportunidad
y ahí ahí estaba ya con un muy buen paso
adelante estaba muy cerca de lo que es
la felicidad incluso estaba seguro de
estar feliz tuve que trabajar y
encontrar una persona más para para
entender el siguiente paso porque hay un
siguiente paso porque realizar tus
sueños te hace muy feliz pero hay algo
más que te puede hacer más feliz esta
persona para mi forma importante y fue
mi profesora durante el doctorado
la doctora carla mare lo que un día
mientras que estaba en la oficina del
doctorado sacó su filial se sentó frente
mío me miró
y dijo constantino
usted qué quiere hacer cuando sea grande
pero no soplo de fue una sorpresa porque
un poquito grande me sentía estaba en un
doctorado
sin embargo y sin embargo fue una
pregunta muy importante porque yo estaba
haciendo algo que me gustaba estaba
siguiendo mis sueños pero no había
pensado que quería hacer cuando sea
grande porque como todo había entrado a
la universidad y no sabía que venía
después
y eso me hizo pensar y me hizo pensar
que a mí me encantaba estudiar idiomas
me encantaba aprender de sus culturas
nuevas me encantaba el contacto con
nuevas poblaciones con nuevos lugares
conocer hablar idiomas nuevos culturas
nuevas y entonces quizás había algo muy
importante que me podía hacer feliz ahí
entendí una cosa sumamente importante
hay solo una cosa que te permite ser más
feliz que alcanzar tus sueños y es
permitir que los otros alcancen sus
propios sueños he decidido dedicarme a
la educación dedicarme a la enseñanza
porque finalmente he pensado si a mí
tanto me gusta debe haber gente en el
mundo que tiene el mismo deseo de ver
gente que quiere estudiar idiomas y
aprender
entonces yo puedo ser ese medio para que
ellos alcancen sus sueños y de verdad
que es el pasito
final para alcanzar alcanzar tu
felicidad porque al final del día es muy
importante eso tú puedes alcanzar tus
sueños pero si estás un paso más y
permites a las personas a tu alrededor
de alcanzar tus sueños ahí puedes
conseguir algo importante y es difícil
claro es difícil pero a este punto ya
sabemos que vale la pena porque muchos
colegas me dicen que soy un soñador de
que es irreal pero al final del día
cuando cuando ha saltado tus almuerzos
porque te estás esforzando pero no por
el esfuerzo sino por unos sueños cuando
has decidido que las cosas que estás
haciendo son buenas y vall de verdad la
pena dejar tu familia al otro lado del
océano o vale la pena trabajar todo el
fin de semana vale la pena saltar los
almuerzos al apenas dedicarte 100% si
has decidido esto al final del día tú
sabes que las ojeras estás despeinado
que estás cansado pero has dado un
granito de arena más y quizás mañana no
estaremos en un mundo perfecto quizás la
próxima semana no estaremos en el país
de las maravillas' pero sabemos si hemos
dedicado el día en hacer algo bueno que
estamos dando un poquito un paso
adelante aunque sea poco mañana será
mejor que hoy día estamos caminando
hacia un mundo más humano y esto es lo
que vale la pena y esto es el secreto de
la felicidad
gracias
[Aplausos]